ladies and gentlemen
welcome to wild ride with stevo this
week is special it is an
undefeated professional boxer and
hands down one of the biggest stars ever
to come out of youtube
oh man he's a rapper he's doing it all
and we're going to get into it ladies
and gentlemen
ksi yeah dude
yo yo yo ah you've met my co-host scott
randolph in morocco yeah we were morocco
and on the same flight together to
morocco
yeah yeah yeah that's right so this is a
long time scott randolph right here and
up front we've got
the gorgeous paul briskey what's up man
how are you
and uh he's gonna be dropping the
samples speaking of which it's a
huge star alert over here
[Music]
i have to say i gotta say dude i was uh
that's pleasantly surprised even shocked
that we that we got you to do this man
thank you oh really
yeah i thought you know obviously you
did this admin show for us so i was like
yeah it's it's only it's only fair
i i do i i just i really appreciate it
and uh it's a it's a big get for us you
know
here on earth on our wild ride podcast
man like
variety magazine is the um like the gold
standard of the entertainment industry
and
in 2015 variety magazine
named you the most influential
celebrity for us teens and
being an english guy what did it feel
like to be the most
influential celebrity for united states
teenagers yeah i know it was it was it
was quite a weird thing
obviously that was um i was at a point
where i was doing quite a lot of youtube
videos i was just
i was quite random with it i did all
types of things skits pranks
uh you know i i was doing videos with my
mates and yeah it just popped off and
i guess americans just loved it yeah
and uh it's kind of crazy how i've like
transitioned from that
to just doing all types of things from
like the boxing to
music well music yeah so it's quite cool
that i'm in a space where i can
pretty much do what i want and just have
fun with it at the age of 27 right
yeah well a lot of my ways to say that
i'm old
now
yeah we're old my god as we uh as we sat
down
you know the the guys set up the this
van as a studio and
you know i sat down i said is it fair to
say
that ksi is every bit
as successful and and huge of uh
a success coming from youtube as jake
paul and logan paul
yet not so polarizing you know like
the fact is when when uh a mainstream
person here's jake paul logo logan paul
there's this like really sort of
widespread
visceral like they're so polarizing and
i don't know that i
that uh i perceive that from you i think
that you are just as big and
and you don't bring about the the hate
so much
yeah there isn't like i guess with me
there isn't
like you don't instantly think
ah suicide forest or
absolute [ __ ]
you don't think you don't really think
of these things obviously like
i have a few haters here and there but
like i'd say a majority
of people that know about ksi or know
about me are like oh yeah
he's uh he's that guy that did boxing
and he also
does music in youtube and you know he
seems like a pretty nice guy
he seems pretty approachable and you
know my kids love him so you know i'm
okay
i'm okay with it i'm just like you know
i'm not really
someone that would irritate anyone if
that makes sense well congrats on that
man
yeah thank you for that that's what
everyone's everyone's trying to aim for
and for some reason
some people don't want to do that i
think i do
pretty well in that regard you know i
mean there's certain people that are
gonna be
haters like oh man to screw that guy but
uh yeah but there wasn't any instance in
your life where like people always like
refer back to when they think of stevo
right that i mean yeah
they think of like you know chicken up
the butt with the alligator or fish hook
in the mouth
i've had so many like bad publicity
moments
and like i love them all
yeah you know i mean i don't know like
not gotten wood i suppose you know but
uh
yeah i think things go pretty well in
that regard so with so with uh
you know logan paul of course is like
such a uh just
epic like landmark moment in history
when you
and logan paul fought both times and
uh i get you know what i what i think i
i'm curious to know and i really don't
know
is there any like sort of bad blood is
there any
beef between you guys um
i think i think there's just a high
level of respect
there's always going to be respect there
but you know i don't think we'll ever be
friends if that makes sense
i think if you ran into each other like
at a party would it just be like oh hey
man
it would just be really awkward yeah
really awkward yeah
like i think it would just there'll be a
lot of tension like
i don't think we would just stop each
other and go oh what's up man
i know i like i wouldn't go over to him
and i don't know if he would be so i
like
well what do you think about his brother
calling out dana white no no no no
with a passion so it's so funny though
like i saw from dana white
he said that was uh i was the
video game kid from england right i saw
so funny but he follows me on instagram
who do you know
yeah right i mean dude i love we we
love dana white we are such humongous
fans of the ufc there's just like
i mean like we we worship the ufc i do
not
ever miss a fight i [ __ ] love it and
with that said
i you know i hear you're saying i hate
jake paul and i get it like he's so
uh polarizing so abrasive but dude the
the i don't even i can't believe i'm
going to say this
but like his firing back
at dana white his like he's kind of good
at what he does
you know like yeah but he hasn't he
hasn't been tested
right oh yeah i'm definitely not dude
definitely like nate robinson ran into
it
we literally ran into him and got
knocked out like no one fight no that's
not how the fight
it went dude they'd like nate robinson
i mean yeah you make a good point that
for him to say like oh dude come on man
who's next like
yeah let me let me fight conor mcgregor
now what
yeah that's the next that step make any
sense
right that's like fighting someone who's
disabled and then going yeah okay
i can fight uh dwayne johnson now let's
go let's do it all
right oh oh let me let me fight khabib
now
right i mean what are you doing making
sense yeah in that regard it's it's
awful
but then when like just being like sort
of uh a troll
he's good at that he's he's good at i
think getting under people's skin he's
good at it
you know i mean obviously yeah but i
feel like that's easy
like that's easy to do it's so easy very
nice
if you wanted to be a [ __ ] it's so easy
you're a fan of the ufc right oh yeah
yeah i watched the ufc
and do you have any more boxing stuff
coming up that you want to do i mean
maybe you should do a showcase with ian
edwards or something like kind of boxing
or
ian edwards from from england right the
ufc fighter
uh ian edwards is a comedian
sorry shout out to ian edwards but uh
yeah leon edwards
because he did he hasn't been able to
fight leon leon
edwards is uh i mean dude he's a little
bit shot himself in the foot but by
turning down
fights and like he hasn't fought in a
long time i think that
he got a little bit of uh of a bad
kind of uh light on him with his
backstage dust up with jorge mazvidal
yeah he was but he was like but he ran
through
rda i mean we don't have to get into it
i think leon edwards is a
great [ __ ] fighter and him losing the
the hamzat fight was a [ __ ] pisser
but that's not what we're here to talk
about
i saw on your wikipedia you have a movie
credit called
laid in america what a fantastic [ __ ]
name and
what's that about oh wait
have you ever been made in america i
actually have yeah yeah
of course of course come on but um yeah
no it was just uh
an experience but we you know me and
caspar lee
i don't know if you know caspar lee but
we made uh
worked on this movie back in the day i
think in 2014 2015
and uh we just thought it'd be a funny
idea we um
as essentially two uh foreign exchange
students
and we had one more day left before we
went back to our country so
we were like [ __ ] we're both virgins
we need to [ __ ] that's just that's right
so it's literally us just trying to get
laid in america in this final day
and it's just i mean i don't know it's
it could some people see it as a classic
where can they see it it's just
everywhere like it's
like online was it a profitable venture
i imagine it's coming 2014
2014 2015 those were big years for you
so i gotta imagine that that brought in
some dough
i don't think i actually remember me
getting any money
so that was like what was the budget for
the film and who made it
uh i think the budget was about a mill
and um
it's uh these two guys who made it i've
forgotten their names now
but um yeah they were they were pretty
cool like
um i should remember their names i think
one of them was peter
and the other was i forgotten but yeah
they were they were just really cool and
yeah they were just came up to us with
this idea and we're like yeah [ __ ] it
let's do it
i think they would prefer you remember
the name of the movie and to tell people
about the movie
then their names yeah yeah i'm gonna
watch that [ __ ] delayed in america
please don't
please don't don't [ __ ] do that to
yourself oh my god
that's fantastic and and uh so then now
with the rap music
like this is fantastic
that you've got like good critical
response to your music
yeah yeah so you know i'm working on my
next album
um which is coming out this year and
well i'd say
mid maybe july may just around that time
summer and uh yeah man like i obviously
i released an album last year at the
simulation and it did bit
um but this year man i've gone even
like bigger with the people i've got
featuring
you know the production is just even
more big and it's just
it's just such it's just a way better
album than
last last year and uh you know i've
really had time to focus
on my craft work on my flows work on
my singing work and work on my rapping
and
just essentially making the body of what
i'm really
really excited for people to hear and
you know i felt like
the simulation was a nice a nice thing
to just dip my toes in and you know into
the whole
album space and you know i realized what
i
did what i did good in and what i did
bad in and i was like okay cool
let me continue the good and let me work
on the bad and that's essentially what
i've done with this next album and
man like obviously i released a track
with craig david
um released another track this uh this
year with uh anne marie
uh it's out next week friday and um
okay that's the day after this [ __ ]
drops yeah so tomorrow
beautiful yeah [ __ ] interesting so i
had tomorrow
[ __ ] there we go and marie and uh
you know i've got other big features
coming through and
yeah i've got some big songs on my own
as well so it's it's
really exciting and i feel like this is
the part
this is the point where i really get to
showcase how well i'm doing with music
and i don't want to be seen as just
you know a youtuber doing uh music
you know i i want people to see me as an
artist you know i'm an artist i'm a
youtuber i'm a boxer i'm all these
things
and you know i don't want people to take
anything away just because i have
a large fan base so yeah now like even
even
today i got a platinum with um
one of my songs
yeah yeah so you know it's just baby
steps in getting into where i want to
get to so
nice i relate to what you're saying
about not wanting to
have your youtube status detract from
your you know artist status and
with me it's uh my jackass status and
then i got into comedy you know i like
just yeah this [ __ ] guy
shoves [ __ ] up his ass man you can't
just stand up
yeah yeah yeah but yeah dude give a [ __ ]
about it and it's evident that you do
too
um yeah so and i feel like i feel like
you have to work harder
than you know your normal comedians just
to really prove yourself
right to everyone essentially why do you
feel like that with rapping too
yeah yeah i feel like i have to do more
like i feel like i have to be better
than
stormzy like stormzy is the equivalent
to someone like
uh kendrick lamar
or uh or well i mean he's
the biggest rapper in the uk so i
essentially the biggest rapper in the us
i i it could be drake it could be jay-z
could be
whatever but uh for for us
like for me it's like i feel like i need
to make
better music than stormzy for people to
realize like
oh [ __ ] this ksi guy can actually do
music that's like that's
well that's the consensus man one quick
google search
and uh you know you learn right away
that your rap album is well received and
critically acclaimed
man and i think that uh having a
you know a name a profile an audience
like going in from it's a blessing and a
curse because here
like you know yeah people want to [ __ ]
on me doing comedy maybe they want to
try and [ __ ] on you doing rap
and that's the curse but at the same
time we've got a built-in audience so
we're starting with a wayhead
you know starting with a big advantage
well and it's also
it's also not our fault though like you
know
i worked hard to get an audience i
worked hard on youtube to create this
audience
and now if i want to go into music why
is it my fault now
oh you've got a large audience you can't
do that you can't go into music but
i can do whatever the [ __ ] i want father
like if i know i've always been
interested in music i've always loved
doing music i
did music as a kid to help me remember
things in school because i had a
terrible memory
i still do and i always like write stuff
down to make sure i remember everything
that i need to do
and i'm just there like you know i like
i love making music it's a hobby it's
just
it's fun for me so just because i do
well in music
people always like to detract um
my success and go ah just because he's
got a large fan base that's why he's
able to
you know um do well in music but it's
like
okay then why can't every musician have
a large fan base and do well music
you know it's so easy then why don't why
doesn't everyone else do it
because it's not it's not it's not easy
to build a fan base that just
you know are excited for what you put
out
it's hard to do that so yeah that's a
tommy lee said that's when you know you
start blowing up is when you have haters
so like it's kind of yeah yeah for sure
and with that too like when you have the
popularity it's like you kind of get one
chance like okay you've built an
audience so you
you put out the album people will check
it out but if it's not good they're not
going to keep coming back
and same with the stand up same with
everything it's like to keep it going
is a show of the quality of the work
right and thank you paul thank you for
that because i think a lot of a lot of
people have tried to cross over into
stand-up comedy
and uh you know a lot of people kind of
fell on their ass trying that [ __ ]
but like you know when i did it i cared
about it and i
did my whole little comedy circuit and
then i kept coming back around the loop
you know and here you are with the your
new album and it's bigger and better
[ __ ] yeah go us [ __ ] yeah so what are
you gonna do with that rapper money i
see that you're buying real estate left
and right
now that's a juicy question and actually
it turns out that ksi's most
lucrative activity is boxing
and boy can i relate to training really
hard
like ksi does because i'm getting ready
to ride a bicycle from
los angeles all the way down to san
diego where i happen to be
right now and you know what the most
common problem is
for top athletes like myself and ksi
it's drinking too much water
to the point where you actually have
depleted electrolytes
and sodium but there's a solution people
and it's called
element right it's this drink mix
which you mix with water and you pound
it down
and it sets your electrolytes and your
sodium right where you need to be for
hardcore
training and it is my pleasure to share
with you
the most generous offer that any sponsor
has brought to the listeners of wild
ride
are you ready they're gonna give you an
absolutely free sample pack
what's in it you got two
citrus mixes you got two raspberry
two orange and two round flavored all
eight packs are completely free
all you have to pay for is the shipping
and it's only
five bucks now how do you get the offer
you go to
d r i n k l
m n t dot com slash stevo
this deal is not on their regular
website it's
only for you wild ride listeners and it
is only good for the month of january
so once again go to drinkelement.com
devo and try this stuff out be a
hardcore athlete like me
and ksi now let's
talk about money
i mean i'd say i'm getting more money
from crypto bro
bitcoin out of control right now bitcoin
is so
high right now i already uh got rid of
all my bitcoin
i got rid of around 36k because i was
like it's overextended
would you buy in it so when you say 30.
i bought it
around 18. [ __ ] 18 words like
18 000 thousand that's like one share
but you don't have to buy a whole share
when you buy into it you can buy
like as as much money into it as you
want but pre-payment
it would sit at like 13 then the
pandemic hit it dropped down to five
but now it's up to like 39. like it just
is going crazy
yeah it's literally you bought it at 18.
what'd you sell it at
so i sold that around 34. 30.
yeah yeah just a little bit but i put
like a lot
so i've profited well but i put quite uh
i'd say
i i took like half i'm putting to you
know back into my bank and then i'm kind
of just playing with this other cash
that i have
i'm putting it in like ethereum i'm
pulling in like
neo pulling in all these other old coins
because you know i know that as soon as
alt season happens as soon as
bitcoin chills and relaxes a bit then
all season happens and then that's when
you get your 100x you get your thousand
x
on certain coins and then you makes real
good
yeah this [ __ ] guy dude
i'm taking notes over here
okay that's [ __ ] great because i was
picturing that the top three revenue
streams were going to be
youtube adsense well i guess like
there's youtube adsense
there's uh merch there's music
there's boxing but the fastest the
fastest money that i got
was obviously the boxing like you know
six rounds
three minutes that's 18 minutes of
fighting and then i get paid like a
lot a lump sum so that's you know that's
probably the fastest amount that i've
made
was that was the lump sum for the boxing
like
uh the percentage of the pay-per-view
revenue or was it like an established
upfront
lump sum with the first fight it was yes
but then with the second fight it wasn't
i had to deal with the zone
we went so so where which the first
fight was the the first fight was uh
sorry the first fight was
uh whatever how much we make we split in
half and then we both get 50
uh 50 percent right and so that's of the
pay-per-view
yes of the pay-per-view and then the
second fight was just uh this is what
you get
up front this is this is what you get
and then
you just fight which one worked out
better for you
we're uh second one probably probably
the second one yeah
i guess yeah and then he put it all on
bitcoin then he [ __ ] doubled it
did you did you bet on yourself boxing
or
or not uh with the first
ever fight that i did yeah i bet about
like 10k that's all i was allowed to
um do and uh yeah i won this was me
versus joella
right and that was an amateur fight yeah
that was an amateur fight yeah but you
were able to bet
so i was like this is pretty sick but uh
yeah with the second and third fight um
against logan paul i didn't i did that i
was just like what
what's your favorite way to make money
would you like if you can do would you
be playing video games would be doing
pranks on youtube
rapping boxing i'm guessing the music
sounds like the most satisfying thing
for
that were bitcoin this guy got really
happy talking about
um i don't really know like with music i
just enjoy it like i don't
like there was i'd say seven
year seven eight years i've
done music and not really had enough
like got much money from it if that
makes sense
as in like oh it's only recently that
i'm starting to make money from
music but you know i'd say 2018 and
before that
i hardly made the penny i'd say i hardly
made like over a hundred thousand
like and obviously i had like you know
songs that did well and i had streams
but
i never really saw the money i never
really understood it if that makes sense
yeah so you know after i'd say after the
logan fight
the second logan fight you know when i
dropped a song with rick ross and little
baby and
sx that's when you know i signed a deal
there
and we worked on a few things and you
know obviously at that point i had
leverage because i had a fan base and
all this and that so
at that point i was like okay let me
really understand
the whole money side of things and make
sure i'm not getting [ __ ] over because
i mean as you know i kind of just [ __ ]
over for several years when it
comes to music but it's just because i
didn't know anything so
man but but for me it's like with music
it's just like it's just fun so
on youtube it's just fun so i don't
really know i guess crypto
that's great and and you're going to
pursue the boxing i understand right
yeah yeah so i still i want to fight
jake it's just
obviously because of this whole pandemic
it's just literally just
[ __ ] it all right um yeah that's
interesting because
i what is it jake and logan they fight
at the same weight
yeah sorry the cruiserweight is though
everyone fights
what is cruiserweight yeah that's not in
the ufc so i don't know that
so that's uh it's about uh
i'm probably going to this one i think
it's around 82
kg or 81 kg 225 90
yeah kg so i don't know what that's in
pounds
right i mean dude that that's what makes
sense to me it's like
all right like if if anybody wants to
hate on
you know youtubers boxing
then like don't watch yeah i mean
first off don't watch and and [ __ ] it
like i like that that
you get respect from like legitimate
fighting
media like ariel helwani like yo let's
give these people credit
there's an audience for it you know like
i [ __ ] paid
five bucks to watch the the first logan
paul fight with the
with you yeah yeah i mean even though
you guys hate each other's it was only
five bucks right
like um i think i think so yeah five or
ten
yeah it was it wasn't like i think it
might yeah it might have been ten
it might have been ten but yeah it was
[ __ ] it was great i i super enjoyed
it
yeah i remember seeing it at your place
but even though you guys hate each other
is there some marketing strategy
on both parts or is that all agreed upon
before you guys start
he strikes again scott randolph with the
juicy question
and get ready because i've got some
juicy stuff for you myself
i said we were in san diego and we are
at my new warehouse for
tight box packing yep
that's our fulfillment center where we
fulfill all the orders from stevo.com
and how do we do it
the secret is ship station
that's right if you thought 2020 was a
big year for online sales
2021 is going to be way bigger so if
you're not selling stuff online
you are blowing it and it doesn't matter
how much
you're trying to sell it doesn't matter
from where you're trying to sell it
you could be going through amazon etsy
your own website
doesn't matter shipstation will bring
all
of your orders from all of your sales
channels into one
very simple interface and guess what you
can try it absolutely for free
for 60 days all you got to do is go to
shipstation.com and use my offer code
stevo to get a 60 day free trial
that's two months of no hassle stress
free shipping
so go to shipstation.com click the
little microphone at the top of the page
and enter in the offer code stevo that's
shipstation.com enter the offer code
stevo ship station it's time to
make ship happen now let's talk about
logan paul beef
no no it was all just it was all just
organic
no no like it's so funny there are
people who have been like
oh you guys are definitely friends and
well i'm like no
i feel like we were starting to believe
it now because we don't actually like
chill together or talk to each other
yeah right
uh-huh um what were the odds
going into the second fight i guess for
both thoughts
yeah so i was um i wasn't the favorite
i believe for both fights i wasn't the
favorite right does that [ __ ] you out
the dog
is that like i love that [ __ ] i love
that [ __ ] i love when i'm the underdog
because then
there's no pressure then i get to prove
people wrong and you know all my life
i've proven people wrong so i'm just
there like all right
we got another one yo yeah right and so
you don't have to
you don't have to like cut a bunch of
weight to like
it's just you guys fight the same way
jake paul
man i want to see you by jake paul well
i want to fight jay paul as well he's
just
who's dodging who damn it man there's no
one's dodging really like
i mean jake is just [ __ ] he's just
spraying everyone
he's like oh i'll fight you i'll fight
you will fight you but then he's not
fighting anyone but
i think you know obviously the main
fight is between me and him like that's
where
everyone wants to [ __ ] see i think so
it's just it's just to do with
just the pandemic legit like it's
like first for all first first of all
first of all
england is just [ __ ] right now when it
comes to covid like
our cases are just going up and up and
up and like
it's just getting harder and harder to
do anything we're currently in a
lockdown
so i was i was training before you know
um before the lockdown you know in the
gym and just going ham
and now it's like well now it's
it's impossible like i had to just do
everything at home so yeah i'm just
practicing on my own i can't use my
coach i can't
i can't do anything and i it's just i
know it just puts me at a disadvantage
and it's just annoying then
obviously you know with this fight i
want to put my all into it but if i
can't
train properly then it's just like it
kind of [ __ ] it up and then
you know obviously jake lives in america
i live in england so there's
all this and back and forth and then you
know i'm sure he's gonna be like oh well
let's find america but i'm gonna be like
i've already fought in america
let's bring it to england 02 that's why
it has to be
well the first fight with logan was in
england and then the second one was in
america
yeah yeah but you know he always says
that he's the a
side but you know i feel like i'm still
the a side that i am
so it's just i don't know maybe we'll
find a
a place in like dubai where yeah what do
you say the rumble in the jungle where
was that
was that the philippines
rumble in the jungle that uh yeah right
south africa maybe yeah i mean i'm sure
that that there's a way to work out all
those
all those details so uh let's talk about
the merch
like uh we're we're begging to uh
sort of picking people's brains and
figuring out how they do merch
and like of course you got the sidemen
you're wearing the sidemen shirt
yeah do you have your own ksi merch
separate from the sidemen merch or you
just no no
it's all it's all just sidemen like i
just yeah promote the sidemen
most like most of the time if not all
the time then
you know we've been doing it for as long
as we've been doing
you know sidemen as as the channel as a
youtube channel
um and it's funny like we we've only
been able to upload every week because
of the seidman show simon show was the
reason we uploaded every week because we
were like oh we need to
get um people used to seeing us
regularly on youtube uh as a group so
we're like oh let's just
do random video ideas uh and post them
uh so that when we do release the simon
show there'll be a
a lot of people excited to watch it
right and then after that we were like
you know what [ __ ] it let's just
continue and
i think it was the best decision we made
because we have smashed it when it comes
to
youtube when it comes to the clothing
like clothing is just
like it's doing bits the amount of
people are buying
from our from our from our website it's
just
phenomenal okay so when they buy from
the website
where does the actual like
fulfillment fulfilled like where's the
warehouse like the warehouse where they
actually
put it in the box and ship it yeah so
the warehouse is uh
somewhere outside of london um it's
somewhere in kent
and uh yeah we just it's actually uh
getting to a point where we're looking
for a new warehouse
like our warehouse was like huge when we
first entered
is it so it's your warehouse yeah so we
we rent the warehouse yeah
yeah we're looking to uh if you need any
west coast distribution we got you
covered
because i just uh we just rented
our first warehouse we took on our own
fulfillment operation for the first time
yeah dude we had like we had this
third-party company
that was taking all of our orders and
and uh
and we're like dude we can do this so
much better and uh steve came up with a
great name
yeah our fulfillment center is called
tight box
packing tight box
packing yeah you like that yeah we pack
your box nice and tight
okay it's good so you're
just killing it on the merch and and the
relationship between you and all the
all the guys is uh i mean i met you guys
it was
[ __ ] awesome and uh yeah yeah and you
know i think it's cool because
you know what we're friends we're
actually friends it's not like we're
brought together or manufactured
together we're just friends and
you know we have back and forth you know
we uh
squabble every now and then but you know
ultimately we enjoy
doing stuff together you know we talk to
each other every single day
every single day uh and we're just yeah
it's just cool it's just fun with
we've literally just jumped into this
space together
and just fried from it but you know
we've worked hard we've you know it's
it's it's tough making all these videos
here
yeah dude tell me about it for our
audience you know and trying to be
um consistent with it but we've done
pretty well
for sure i feel like our audience
appreciates that yeah i was talking to
knoxville
this morning uh and i'm just saying to
him
how grateful i am that for all the rock
bands
for all the [ __ ] you know ensemble
casts like all these like groups that
just
[ __ ] hate each other the bands that
break up the bands that continue to tour
but they just [ __ ] hate each other
and they ride in different buses and
they're only ever together while they're
on stage
just how grateful i am that that's not
us you know the jackass guys that we've
got
decades and this legacy and that you
know there's this chemistry
you know like i feel like the audience
can definitely see that
like that chemistry whenever there is
that chemistry and then it just
it just beams from the the
the footage that you put out yeah
so it's cool that you can say that as
well
you know yeah yeah and uh like everybody
took it pretty well
where because i remember when uh when
you guys flew me out to morocco
to be on the sidemen show and i remember
the uh
this was when it was still called
youtube red and youtube is really going
after uh
they were really going after their own
original programming
and their model was to shoot a whole
series
but the first episode of the series
they give it to you for free so people
get a chance to like really oh man i
want to watch
the second episode the rest of the
series and that requires them to
actually
sign up for the subscription and if i
remember correctly
uh i got to be the free episode the the
the first episode
yeah yeah to wrap everybody in yeah all
the light bulbs with your ball sacks
presumably uh that that minute got the
most viewership and
and uh i was really [ __ ] cool that um
that like the big mark keystone i'll
never forget i was sitting in a hotel
room
like uh and i thought oh man like i want
to uh
try to dive off a roof and break as many
light bulbs as possible
with my balls and like you're sort of
jumped sideways with my legs spread and
just
and i drafted up this this like frame
that would need to be built
with like a stick figure drawing and i
like emailed it to the producers
and when i showed up in morocco they
literally built exactly what i drew
and for the most part the stunt actually
kind of [ __ ] worked exactly the way i
pictured it
and then when uh when the show was
coming out i said hey guys
here's the deal i know that this like
light bulb stunt is
like the big sort of grand finale of the
show i know that it's like the
the big moment but uh you know i don't i
don't have to [ __ ] promote your thing
but but if you want me to
like i'll make my own video for my own
channel to promote your sidemen show
but my condition is you gotta let me
show the whole [ __ ] lightbulb bit and
they were like right on dude [ __ ]
here you go
so you know yeah i put it on my channel
and uh i was like i remember at the
beginning of the video on my channel i
said
you know if you haven't heard of this oh
yeah yeah no i said yeah i saw that i
saw that literally we
we put in the chat we're like oh [ __ ]
why steve wrote on this
right yeah i said if you haven't heard
of the side man you've been living under
a [ __ ] rock you should be ashamed of
yourself or something like that
and uh yeah i was real i was really
stoked that they let me put that on my
channel it did great
and uh it's such a fun time such a
[ __ ]
fun time in morocco is that your first
time
all right we had been to morocco like uh
we had been morocco
but dude it was just it was it was a
really [ __ ] great time in my life
like
we had just filmed this opening sequence
for my my new comedy special that i put
out on my own website
where i was duct taped to the side of a
truck and they're driving down
the highway yeah we had just filmed that
and i just
i was like dude this i made a hit you
know like this [ __ ]
thing with me on the truck and this
whole project that that
was for it's a hit you know and i just
felt like
remember so we're in morocco i'm staying
at the hotel we're smoking this [ __ ]
tobacco hookah
on the roof and i said to scott i said
you know man
i feel like i'm getting like i got some
momentum in my career right now and uh
you know like and i found my girl you
know like i found like the
the i finally got a relationship that's
stable and that
that like i'm like everything's just
going so good for me
and and i don't want to have kids i
think i want to [ __ ] like pour myself
into helping animals
and we're sitting on that roof and scott
says you should open up your own
you should open up your own animal
sanctuary and i was like [ __ ] yeah and
so
that's where it came to consensus that's
where it all came in now like we've got
like here at my house in the hollywood
hills we built a little [ __ ] barn
we got three goats running around
everywhere we got [ __ ]
four dogs [ __ ] two cats like and uh
and we're shopping for property
to put to [ __ ] open up an animal
sanctuary
and covered and covered been [ __ ]
that up
yeah it all went down in morocco when i
was chilling with you guys thanks to the
sidemen
and i had long since quit smoking
cigarettes
right we [ __ ] flew home from morocco
we connected in london and i'm like
scott
going to the [ __ ] hook bar we
shut up at this bar they were closed
like we're like and we had
them to open it up and like 12 o'clock
at night they opened it up
yeah and then and then we [ __ ] uh
fly from london to to l.a and i got like
a car service picks me up at the airport
and i'd tell the [ __ ]
the driver i'm like like you stop at the
[ __ ] store
and then i bought a hookah on the way
home from the [ __ ] airport and just
sat there
i'm like what am i doing i got myself
addicted to [ __ ] tobacco again
and then we went back on the road to go
tour and the part of the rider was a
hookah
yeah and then i ended up like i ended up
going to like my little sobriety support
group
and being like yo guys dude i [ __ ]
i'm acting out with
tobacco like i was not okay like i would
have like a hookah like you know
three times a week steve would have it
like four times a day i would not i
would i would say
oh dude i would i would like do it all
day i wasn't breathing
air i was just i would come over like go
to hookah i'm like
yeah of course
that's also thanks to the sidemen yeah
yeah
okay that went on for like
maybe three weeks or something that's it
i think it was like
i think it was a little under a month
and then i [ __ ] threw away the hookah
yeah dude but it was just a great it was
a great time
and uh yeah just so rad man
so you guys you got your own full you do
your shipping operation
that's essentially that's a separate
business from where you got merch
and then there's the shipping and then
and then there's
so i don't deal with any of that so we
have a guy called matt
who deals with all of the simon clothing
because uh that [ __ ] is just complicated
yeah it's a job in itself oh yeah so we
were just like there's no way we're
gonna be able to do it that
it would just be overkill so we kind of
just let matt do his thing
and uh he smashed it man he's really
like taking us to another level with
when it comes to the whole clothing man
and yeah
we're just trying to get to logan paul's
levels of
uh making uh a million in a day
i mean logan paul [ __ ] hustles man
i was on his podcast like i think i was
like one of like the first 10 guests
on logan paul's podcast and i saw that
he
just had mike tyson on and what blew my
mind was it said like
episode 200 and something like wait what
logan paul's put out 200 [ __ ]
podcasts
in like maybe a couple years jesus dude
is [ __ ]
dude works man like you know i got
you know i i just got to give it to
those guys they you know and
i've been banging my head against the
wall for years because i'm thinking like
i'm not lazy there's nothing [ __ ]
lazy about
me like i've worked my [ __ ] ass off
but like where's all the money
[Laughter]
what am i not what am i doing wrong you
know steve two words
bitcoin
bitcoin ethereum bro you're missing that
theory
right dude it's crazy rap career boxing
yeah i have a question i have a question
about the rap career like
yeah these killer features on your uh on
your project like offset and rick ross
and i've always just been curious what's
the process of doing that do you send
them the song do you meet up in the
studio
like do they just send you something
they recorded and i made
i made i made the tracks and then i i'd
go
who would work for this so with the
offset we were like okay
um we also said yeah yeah would you be
down
to up on this track with me and yeah he
just said yes
you know obviously he did his thing and
then yeah we release it same with uh
rick ross same with little baby it's
kind of just
you know you make the track and you just
send it to them
and i didn't really get in the studio
with them it's kind of like they just
did their thing and then i did my thing
and then we just bring it together did
you have like a a creative approach to
making a music video where
you'd like to send in the footage from
different parts of the world
uh no no so i with music all the music
videos like we'd meet up
oh great for the music yeah for the
music videos we meet up
and uh i remember um when i met offset
he was just
off his face man he was just [ __ ]
just
gone but he was just like yo
like i was like why
yeah i was like he wasn't even speaking
english to me
but uh as soon as we played the track he
was like oh
yeah it's just jamming out
and as soon as the music stopped he just
just sat down and just
went back into his shell yeah what power
to it man
that's where that yeah who are the dream
features for your next project
i can't say yeah
dreaming it doesn't even apply it's like
what are you gonna make happen next
right yeah i'm interested that
did you ever put the jacuzzi on the
penthouse via the helicopter oh
[ __ ] no no we never managed to do that
so close uh so the person who actually
owned
uh the building uh said no
yeah sorry so so you bought the building
[Laughter]
yeah i'm done like so instead i was like
yeah [ __ ] it like oh my god i'd have
been sick like we're gonna have a
helicopter
literally take this [ __ ] jacuzzi and
just land it on
the rooftop of uh flat
but uh yeah they they just said nah they
just couldn't believe it they were just
like
is are you serious i was like yeah i
want a jacuzzi
i want a jacuzzi on my mind yeah for
sure
i got i got a [ __ ] jacuzzi man a
bodice that i could jump off the roof of
my house
into the jacuzzi and that was like that
made my top 10 injury list
wait you surely just was in the pool
right now i dropped into a hot tub in my
butt
why would you do that my butt turned
into like a [ __ ]
alien from mars like [ __ ] growing out
like
it was an awful injury because you hit
the cause you know how hot tubs like
they
they carve out where you can sit and
your butt butt landed like right
to the bench yeah like right in between
yeah
yeah it was terrible man we did it with
david dobrik
yeah oh
[Music]
wait no wasn't that wasn't that with uh
with the ice so what's it called yeah
yeah the driver
yeah that was the same day oh my so you
did both
i did both back to back and now the hot
tub was first
yeah that was the warm-up and if my
truck record
if my track record for jumping into
shallow water isn't bad enough now i'm
trying to go for the
the highest ever belly flop into just 12
inches
of pure piss that's yeah just to throw
it out there not his own
well mostly my own we're collecting i've
got like so far i've collected
uh 28 gallons of piss
and then the pool that i bought
for it uh has a 13 inch fill line which
says takes 157 gallons to fill
wait wait surely that's not hygienic
surely there's something
something bad the longer you keep it the
the grosser it gets and by the time i uh
collect 157 gallons of pea it's not
gonna be new and fresh you're going to
jump in and just start
puking instantly perhaps perhaps
right but that's coming off a roof and
uh and i got to be in full skydive
position
belly nothing but belly oh my god yeah
it's ambitious man it's uh
and then sometimes i just throw it out
there what my ideas are like
hey man because yeah what what how do
you even come up with your ideas like
piss yeah yeah what what is the most
painful thing that i can do
in the most coolest way ever that's
actually what you
i get i never mind throwing out my ideas
before i do them because i'm confident
nobody's gonna steal them
i want to jerk off jumping out of an
airplane it's like yeah dude that was my
for my new tour and my next comedy
special that like
that the closer is is me butt naked in
an airplane with the guys strapped to my
back
and i'm fully wanking and i fall out of
the airplane simultaneously blowing a
load
at 15 000 feet in the air it's called
sky jacking yeah
that's a big one
and that's after the vasectomy yeah the
vasectomy olympics was a good one
but in any case man what can we uh help
you promote right now i i i
promote i have i have a sense this is
gonna be a wildly successful podcast
i'm sure i'm sure you've done bigger
shows but
i anticipate this between the audio and
the video version
clearing like i don't know 300 400 500k
in a pretty short time so we're talking
to an audience
and uh what do we want that audience to
do what's the call to action
um i'm ksi
yeah and and how about how about
everybody that's what
let's let's rally rally the the audience
to [ __ ] to scream for the ksi versus
jake paul
fight i mean they've already been
screaming for it it's just
we can't do it okay what about the rap
album
all right what about the rap album where
are we going oh yeah it's coming out
uh mid mid uh mid this year
here's the question let's go wild away
what if
like you said your music is essentially
lives everywhere but what is your
personally preferred
platform for people to uh to get your
music
presumably itunes so that they buy it oh
you're not spotify
it's just free yeah just listen for free
what platform pays you the most money
for uh disseminating your music
um i'd say
i'll probably say streaming streaming is
right that's spotify
yeah nice is that awesome music
you get checks you get checked
separately from spotify from
apps no no no no no no so um because of
my deal
uh i've i've already been paid so i'm
just recouping right now
okay so like so same with like youtube
like
yeah i got paid a lump sum and it's like
now i'm just recouping everything
so all right i don't get paid on my
youtube videos i don't get paid
uh my music but you know i'm actively
trying to recoup because i don't know
it's like
a goal for me and that it kind of helps
with my mindset
for me to work harder and harder just to
make sure i recoup
and i also own my masters and everything
so it's like
it's all like all in my favor and it's
all pretty that's the ticket man i own
my [ __ ] comedy specials
when you when you say recouping so you
there was a budget you put money into
the project and it's about getting that
money back
is that what you is that what you mean
by that well yeah but i didn't put any
money in so
i think i think what it means i think
what it means is that like he signs with
the label
like whatever like uh the situation is
they pay him a lump sump up front
and there's an agreement that once the
people who paid him his lump sump
have recouped that then it becomes a
profit sharing situation from that point
forward
so you haven't so yeah you haven't uh
you haven't
reached you haven't realized your back
end potential
yeah you haven't gotten into the back
end yeah but i feel like i'll recoup uh
by the end of this year
so i signed in 2019 at the end of 2019
right and uh yeah i feel like yeah end
of this year i'll recoup good so
so uh so again what what do we have a
preferred platform for people to go
check out your music
spot oh just spotify apple music yeah
just
uh amazing music yeah and we're edward
and we're petitioning we're petitioning
for the jake paul fight we want to get
behind that
yeah and we want to drive as much
traffic as we can to laden america
that's what we're promoting and uh
and if you don't have sidemen gear
you're
just not [ __ ] cool so are you british
if you don't have sidemen gear
remember remember the most the most
influential celebrity for us
teens that's like [ __ ] the beatles
dude if you're american and you don't
have sidemen gear you're blowing it i
happen to have [ __ ] multiple
sidement hoodies in my closet i don't
know why i'm not wearing it right now
[ __ ] dude
all right brother hey dude like honestly
man thank you
i was uh no thank you man truly truly
like surprised and honored to be able to
do this with you man and
uh oh my god good good
that was easy man i jumped on your
instagram too man i don't know what took
me so long dude but uh
[ __ ] i saw 8.9 million followers on
there that's something
let's crack that nine mil oh yeah
yeah i got it what the [ __ ] man let's
let's let's
let's make it an even ten a nice round
there we go yeah
awesome dude hey brother we'll let you
get back to your day
and [ __ ] thank you nah pleasure take
care guys yeah dude great talking to you
take it easy you know what dude i love
that guy
my favorite quote of the show it's easy
to be a [ __ ]
yeah dude go ksi and
as always i want to thank you guys for
sticking around to the very end
it's been a real treat to do this from
tight box packing
this is the actual tight box room that
i'm standing in right now
so i do want to show you one last room
if you're watching on youtube
because we are ready to pull the trigger
on the autographed stevo skateboards
they're actually
live on steebo.com right now
so go ahead and grab it you know what
i'm proud to tell you
is that if you go on like
californiacheapskates.com a pro model
skateboard
it's like 65 bucks you get a stevo pro
model skateboard made by
watson laminates and it's autographed
65.99 yeah i'm proud of that and
i love you guys man thank you